weiter geht es bei uns mit zoff um sonn
und feiertags verbote für motorradfahrer
wir fühlen uns von der bundespolitik im
stich gelassen
das sagen die motorradfahrer bereits am
vergangenen wochenende hatten bundesweit
zehntausende motorradfahrer gegen
fahrverbote aus lärmschutzgründen
demonstriert hintergrund ist ein
beschluss des bundesrates der die
bundesregierung auffordert solche
zeitlich befristeten einschränkungen
beispielsweise an sonn und feiertagen
durchzusetzen
damit der lärm etwa in beliebten
ausflugs gegenden reduziert werden kann
so war die theorie also jetzt sprechen
wir mit echten motorradfreaks fahrern
und fans und zwar haben wir einmal mario
veit
harry in der leitung die beiden sind an
der spinner brücke und das ist ein
beliebter motorrad treffpunkt in berlin
überall wo die beiden bleiben so mario
feiler
hier haben wir euch hallo schön brutal
weil ihr seid natürlich gegen das verbot
was meint ihr wäre ein kompromiss nur
noch leise motorräder zuzulassen wäre es
nicht normaler motorräder haben
teilweise schon geringen geräuschpegel
er ist ein heute modernes auto
da viele fahrzeuge teilweise solitude
werden dass sie mit klappen auspuff bzw
sound generator fahren werden wir
meistens nicht mehr übersehen denn wenn
auch überhört und
da stellt sich für uns die frage man
machte aus ihr euch oder aus dem herben
gründen aber lernen so für uns ist
einfach lernen eine andere auffassung
wie für andere das heißt mit anderen
worten wir uns immer wichtig
herauszufinden was wirklich für jeden
tag stellen es gibt keine richtige
messung war wie viele es wirklich lernen
beziehungsweise wieviel db jemand sich
davon gestört fühlt
versteh das argument aber warum müssen
motorräder laut sein oder müssen die
überhaupt für euch laut sein also laut
in dem fall waren sie zum beispiel
selber motorrad zb als autofahrer ist
zum beispiel wichtig wenn sie zum
beispiel im toten winkel haben und sie
sehen kein motorrad aber sie können es
hören
das würde das ist einfach mal dass es
viele unfälle vermeidet dafür das ist
halt einfach man muss man sie da hören
um
stimmt eigentlich schon der
verkehrssicherheit wenn man normales
motorengeräusche hat extrem laut sollte
natürlich gute rede auch nicht sein weil
es ja auch im endeffekt dann auch auf
die gesundheit gehen kann
aber wie ich wäre für uns dass man
normal hörbar ist und normales
zugelassenes der zeit des zulassens mit
in der cmdb grenzen ist schon mal sehr
gut zuhören und verhindern indem sie
nach oben sondern okay an dieser stelle
würde ich sagen wir schauen noch mal
kurz in die proteste rein rührend
knattern hunderte bikes am samstag durch
berlin ein erneuter protest gegen das
drohende sonntagsfahrverbot unter dem
motto sind wir zu laut bist du zu alt
bereits am vergangenen wochenende hatten
zehntausende motorradfahrer bundesweit
demonstriert der wichtigste punkt auf
der biker agenda freiheit werden
dazu brauchen wir arbeiten und ende der
woche durch
auslöser für die protestaktionen war ein
beschluss des bundesrats mitte mai er
forderte von der regierung härtere
strafen für tuning am auspuff eine
senkung der zulässigen
geräuschemissionen sowie die einführung
zeitlich beschränkter motorrad
fahrverbot an sonn und feiertagen
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer
reagierte prompt und erteilte den
forderungen eine pauschale absage biker
fahrverbot nein danke die aktion der csu
sie unterstütze ich gerne weil ich habe
auch klar gemacht dass die
verschärfungen verbote nicht der
richtige weg sind
eine haltung die rainer bleek überhaupt
nicht in den kram passt
der bürgermeister des
nordrhein-westfälischen wermelskirchen
fühlt sich von der bundespolitik im
stich gelassen
die straßen rund um die 35.000 einwohner
gemeinde sind bei bikern beliebt um
gegen die vermehrten unfälle und gegen
den lärm vorzugehen wurde auf einer
kreisstraße ein tempolimit von 60 km/h
verhängt eine entscheidung mit folgen
ja ich bekomme drohbriefe
impfungen die biker fühlen sich zu
unrecht ausgebremst
der großteil fährt regelkonform mit
erlaubte lautstärke
doch bürgermeister blick geht es darum
die schwarzen schafe zu erwischen
die zehn bis 15 prozent die sich nicht
an die regeln halten mit ihren rührenden
lauschangriffen natürlich kann ich das
verstehen wir nicht schon gern ein
tempolimit in kauf wenn ich meine
maschine am wochenende aus fahren will
aber hier muss man einfach sehen es geht
so nicht weiter und die motorradfahrer
müssen einfach sich rücksichtsvoll
verhalten
ich bin für einen interessenausgleich
aber nicht für dieses rücksichtslos
gefahren
ja wir haben es jetzt zu sehen es gibt
wirklich streit in diesem punkt mario
und mary für alle zum verständnis er
liebt es ihr seid echte motorradfahrer
was macht die freiheit aus warum liebt
die es motorrad zu fahren und warum
wollt ihr auch diese volle freiheit
haben
also ich muss sagen ein einziges
transportmittel ist tatsache nur ein
motorrad habe kein auto ebenfalls dem
fahrrad also für mich ist es nicht nur
ein hobby
und dass die geselligkeit der
zusammenhalt und die loyalität die ist
unter bikern gibt wie lebt man nicht nur
sondern für mich ist es halt auch ein
fortbewegungsmittel und wenn ich am
wochenende nicht mehr samstag/sonntag
irgendwie fahren könnte es wäre schlimm
also nur weil es ein paar schwarze
schafe gibt jeden weiter auf einmal
unter generalverdacht zu stellen und die
in ihre freiheit zu nehmen es ist ein
lifestyle ist einfach
wie beide leben nach grundsätzen
schuldig ist wichtig dass die einfach
schön lander da sind dass wir uns
miteinander austauschen können dass wir
am wochenende die möglichkeit haben auch
für uns selber eine möglichkeit zu
finden den kopf stellen und eine
arbeitswoche freizubekommen
wenn man uns ist auch nehmen möchte und
gesamte verbotskultur weitergeführt wird
und wir sind natürlich so dass man wir
uns später aber nicht halt machen wollte
im endeffekt wird es jeden treffen
tourismus gastronomie und die hersteller
und wir sagen einfach mit unserer stimme
das wild nicht zulassen wollen weil wir
einfach unser recht freie mobilität
wahrnehmen wollen die art der mobilität
auch selbst bestimmen können das ist für
uns immer wichtig dass wir unsere art zu
leben und unsere freiheit genießen
können wir uns einfach mit unseren
brüdern schwestern austauschen